It's great to be back from the Thanksgiving
holiday here in the United States.
I didn't do much.
I will talk about it on the bonus show.
And the reason I didn't do much is with vaccines
for coronavirus so close.
Why would I do anything at this crucial time
with light at the end of the tunnel to make
the spread potentially even worse?
And unfortunately, it looks like it's going
to get really, really bad.
We don't yet have the numbers that will tell
us the impact of the Thanksgiving travel.
Reportedly almost as many people as in a normal
year, a non pandemic year flying around for
Thanksgiving.
We won't know the impact of that in terms
of cases for a couple of weeks and in terms
of deaths for a couple of more weeks.
Beyond that, because of the timeline of these
spike and super spreader events.
But even without the numbers that will be
caused by Thanksgiving travel and gatherings,
the United States coronavirus pandemic is
completely out of control.
And Donald Trump insisted in the run up to
the election that it was all political after
the election.
You're not going to hear anything else about
the virus.
November 4th, everything, open schools, everything,
everything, everything opens.
Obviously, this has not happened.
And the opposite is actually the truth.
In terms of cases per capita, the United States
has risen to sixth, most cases per capita
in the world, excluding a couple of really
tiny countries and territories, places like
Andorra, which kind of throw off the data.
Similarly, when it comes to deaths using that
same standard, the United States has the seventh
highest rate of deaths per capita in the world.
These are horrifying numbers now in terms
of cases and deaths in the U.S.
The U.S. now has roughly.
Thirteen point seven million known cases and
two hundred and seventy three thousand known
deaths.
The numbers for both could be 30 or even 50
percent higher, as we've previously described.
Remember, Trump said 15 cases will soon be
zero.
Nobody here has died.
We might have 50000 deaths, maybe, but probably
not.
And on and on and on.
We are at two hundred and seventy three thousand.
Nothing is being done at this point in time.
Now, recall that we had a spike in April to
about 32000 cases per day, and at the time
it looked like a big spike.
And then they dipped back down.
And then we had a second spike in July that
doubled that up to about 70000 cases per day.
And it seemed crazy and they started to decline.
But Dr. Foushee said, if we are not careful,
we will get beyond 100000 cases per day in
the fall.
And half the country didn't believe Dr. Anthony
Fauci.
And looking at the chart of those cases, those
initial spikes now look like mere molehills
compared to the current numbers where we saw
as many as one hundred and seventy eight thousand
cases in a single day a few days ago.
Now, over the last few days, because of the
holiday, combined with weekend reporting,
which tends to be lower, we see a bit of a
dip.
We expect to see those numbers caught up on
in the next few days.
And of course, it's not just cases, it's also
deaths, deaths spiking.
We are back up to the numbers of that horrible
early spike of about 2000 deaths a day.
We even had 2300 deaths in a single day last
week.
And it is completely possible and plausible
that these numbers are going to keep climbing
due to Thanksgiving gatherings now heading
into Christmas and New Year's.
There are people who are just determined to
live as if everything is completely normal,
large indoor gatherings.
It is going to be insane.
Now, as I mentioned earlier, we are very close
to vaccines.
We are expecting at this point it is it is
no longer a pipedream.
We are expecting that there will be people
being vaccinated on either December 11th or
December 12th, December eight to 10.
The FDA's meeting with these nonpartisan advisory
boards to say, are we doing an emergency use
authorization, at least for the Fizer vaccine?
And then we'll see if the Moderna vaccine,
it would be discussed at that same time.
Or maybe that will take a little bit longer.
If that is the case.
Vaccines are already being transported.
United Airlines flights bringing vaccines
from Belgium to Chicago for further distribution.
The logistics are on the move.
We are this close.
We could have twenty million people vaccinated
by the end of December.
We could have another 30 million by the end
of January, another 30 to 35 million by the
end of February.
So what that means is that in the next three
months, it's basically December by the in
December, January, February, we could potentially
have 80 to 85 million people vaccinated by
the last day of February.
We are getting close.
This is not the time to behave irresponsibly
and see this absolutely almost cartoonish
rise in cases.
Dr. Fauci saying to Martha Raddatz over the
weekend that you could see this looks like
a surge.
You could see Thanksgiving and Christmas accelerated
even more to a surge upon a surge.
Let's not do it.
This has nothing.
Trump failed.
Yes, Trump failed.
Trump's got days left in his presidency.
Let's get this under control because we are
so, so close and we'll keep you posted on
the numbers and the data.
But it is looking very, very ugly so far